thank you
the president of Colombia Gustavo Petro
came to power in 2022 with great
Promises of change in practically all
political social and economic sectors of
the country you could say that the new
president set out to reform Colombia
from top to bottom one of these major
changes is precisely its energy
transition plan which surprisingly as it
may seem involves an Abrupt halt to any
new oil exploration and exploitation
contracts in Colombian territory in
other words Colombia could become one of
the first main oil powers to veto this
industry if not the first in the world
and keep in mind we are talking about
one of the most important economic
sectors the one that contributes the
most money to the public offers and the
top one in terms of exports the question
is what could all this mean for Colombia
to break with the oil industry why are
they doing it what are they going to
sacrifice to such a measure even makes
sense well this video will answer all of
these questions so let's get cracking
[Applause]
[Music]
with proven reserves of nearly 2 billion
barrels Colombia is among the 35
countries with the largest reserves of
black gold in the world specifically
there are 23 geological zones in this
country with various basins of which
only nine produce hydrocarbons seven
produce oil and two produce gas
of the seven crude oil producing basins
only three account for more than 90 of
Productions these are the Eastern Plains
the Middle Valley and the upper
Magdalena Valley basins in total of the
20 departmental units that currently
extract oil only one extracts light oil
while the rest produce medium or heavy
crude
these would be roughly the details as
you can see the Colombian oil profile is
not exactly that of a country like Saudi
Arabia but it does have potential
although surprisingly they had a hard
time making the most of it stay tuned
because we're going to go back to where
this whole story gets going
[Music]
allergy to profitability
the first oil well in the history of
Colombia was drilled in 1918 in the
Sierra in fantas field where barely 2
000 barrels per day were produced three
years later the country's first Refinery
was built and the first oil pipeline was
constructed in mamonal near Cartagena
and this is how the Colombian oil
industry was launched more than 100
years ago however for a long time no
profit was made from this industry in
1951 seeking to turn this situation
around the government of laureano Gomez
nationalized and granted several oil
concessions to the newly formed Empresa
Colombiana de petroleos Echo Petro a
company created so that the Colombian
State could actively participate and
promote this industry and so although
Giants of those years such as Texaco and
shell began to take an interest in
Colombian oil the exploration and
extraction conditions were totally
disadvantageous for them the presence of
ecopetrol was the main stumbling block
the government only had eyes for it and
the entity was not only a company that
competed in Exploration and production
but also acted as the public body that
regulated the sector so in one way or
another all private companies were
obliged to partner with their virtual
competitor on unattractive terms
therefore throughout almost all the
entire 20th century various legal
regimes were tried and tested which to
tell the truth seemed to go from bad to
worse
[Music]
for example between 1974 and 1989 a
regime called 50 50 contract operated
which had the measure of promoting
investment however under this framework
the private partner assumed the cost and
risk of the exploration investment which
had to be completed within a maximum
period of three years however when
production began the remaining profit
was distributed as followed 20 for the
state and royalties 40 for Echo petrol
and 40 for the private investor of
course the private investor then had to
pay the corresponding profit taxes the
result between 85 and 90 of the
exploitation profits went to the state
the private investor barely received the
rest which not surprisingly was pretty
unattractive
in 1987 an attempt was made to improve
this regulation although attempt is a
bit of an overstatement the only thing
that was changed was the echo petrol
took a higher participation in the cost
of exploration but it did not change the
model in general terms therefore in 1989
a new regime was implemented which would
remain in force until 1994. then the
figure known as the production sharing
contract was created in this scheme the
private partner assumed the exploratory
cost and risk until the discovery was
made at that time Echo petrol would
participate as follows
as you can see the more profitable the
discovered well was the lower the
proportion of profits that was left for
the investor if this model attracted a
flood of investment it must have done so
far from Colombian oil because in fact a
field with barely 60 million barrels was
already scarcely profitable of course
this model didn't work so in 1995 a new
formula was launched called the r factor
in this case production distribution was
based on the profitability of the oil
field without taking into account the
magnitude of the reserves however it was
not at all easy to calculate the
expected revenues and profits which
produced a lot of uncertainty an
uncertainty that not surprisingly scared
off all those other investors so now I'm
sure you understand why Colombia's oil
wealth was barely exploited during
practically the entire 20th century and
the main interested party in the growth
of production was the state itself which
took most of the benefits in the terms
of taxes and royalties so I'm sure I'm
pretty certain many of you have the
solution in your head it seems kind of
obvious however it did take a long time
to arrive check this out
take off
all was not lost though during Andre
Pastrana's presidency Echo petrol made a
very important move during what is known
as the round 2000 call the state made a
series of tenders to explore and produce
in projects in which the state-owned
company would only have a 30 share of
course this caught the attention of the
world's major oil powers to give you an
idea this initiative culminated in the
awarding of 13 projects with an initial
investment of more than 600 million US
Dollars however the bigger change for
the Colombian oil sector was yet to come
in 2003 then president Alvaro Uribe
Velez ordered the restructuring of the
sector going straight to the root of the
problem the Colombian government of the
time created the national hydrocarbons
agency so the echo petrol lost its
regulatory powers and so the public
company would be completely focused on
exploration production Transportation
refining and commercialization of
hydrocarbons in other words it became an
oil company in the usual sense of the
term at the same time the Garment
implemented a new royalty tax and fee
contract the new model mimicked
International standards and limited
State's total share to a range of 50 to
60 of extracted profits and you know
what happened from that moment on
production skyrocketed and with it so
did exports suddenly the Colombian oil
sector came to life take a look at this
and so while Venezuelan production was
falling Colombia was gaining more and
more presence in Latin America's oil
sector the production levels reached
would have been completely unimaginable
just a few years earlier of course there
were also some problems the drop in oil
prices in 2015 reduced investment in
this sector by about 30 and the drilling
of new wells by more than 80 percent the
government of Juan Manuel Santos then
needed to propose a tax reform to
contain the drop in tax revenues
generated by oil let's just say that the
Colombian treasury had become very
dependent on the new public revenues
brought in by the Black Gold but let's
not get sidetracked in spite of
everything the sector Consolidated and
hydrocarbon exports continue to gain
strength among Colombian exports today
the industry is responsible for slightly
more than one-third of all Colombian
exports in a way we are talking about a
kind of oil miracle that contributed to
changing the country in just a decade
between 2003 and 2013 the country went
from almost having to import crude oil
to becoming a major supplier to
countries such as the United States and
do you know what right now with the lack
of investment that for years has been
happening in the international oil
industry and the Russian invasion of
Ukraine has brought forth the
possibility of Colombia experiencing a
new golden era of hydrocarbons however
the new president has said no the oil
exploitation has no place in Colombia
check this out
[Music]
foreign
at the end of 2021 in the midst of
Colombia's presidential election
campaign the future of the oil industry
was a relevant topic on the candidates
economic agenda the most forceful
possession was that of a Gustavo petrol
who promised nothing less than the
cessation of oil concessions check this
out Una
says
Colombia
productive
[Music]
well that candidate ultimately became
the present elect of the Republic of
Colombia on the 19th of June 2022 and in
November of 2022 just one year after his
promise he launched an even more daring
speech at the UN climate change
conference check this out
carburos
is
pretty cool but wait because the real
bombshell came on the 19th of January
2023 when Irene Valez minister of minds
and energy confirmed that the government
will no longer sign new oil exploration
contracts
the exploration
naturally this has generated a lot of
fear not only in the oil sector but in
the entire industry and practically the
entire Colombian economy will this
country lose one of its most important
sources of dollars in public income is
security of Supply at risk
[Music]
you see Colombia currently holds 330
exploration and exploitation contracts
which will continue to produce
hydrocarbons for both the domestic
market and for export for approximately
10 years the question is what happens
after that well this is what president
Petro says according to International
Energy agency projections we have five
years of coal exports and 10 years of
oil exports the transition has to do
with two aspects one to ensure that the
foreign currency we lose from coal and
oil exports is replaced to the same
extent by exports of clean energy and
tourism mainly two getting our own
internal consumption of coal and oil to
be replaced by electrifying
Transportation changing our energy
Matrix and decarbonizing production
Gustavo Petro 21st to January 2023
there will be a strict NG transition but
maintaining oil exports at levels that
will allow us to have the foreign
currency the country needs I would say
that the oil transition will last about
15 years Jose Antonio acampo Minister of
Finance and Public Credit of Colombia in
other words he seems to have more or
less of a plan to force the energy
transition the question is will it be
achieved in 10 years is it worth losing
billions of dollars of potential Revenue
in a country that is still very poor and
has so many shortcomings and fundamental
areas such as infrastructure
[Music]
at the end of the day the data is clear
this is compelling stuff the hydrocarbon
industry is fundamental for the
country's economic stability National
financing and that of the Departments
and municipalities nearly 40 percent of
exports depend on this sector 20 of the
nation's fiscal income and 76 of
royalties diversifying the export basket
must be an objective but not at the cost
of withering the industry communique of
the Colombian Oil and Gas Association
20th January 2023. so it seems
visualpolitic viewers the controversy
and the fear of losing billions of
dollars in foreign investment and public
revenues was such that petrol himself
seems to have kind of backtracked at
least partially yes he does continue to
Target the hydrocarbon industry and
possibly the granting of new exploration
and production licenses will plummet but
at least the energy transition plan
presented includes new concessions be
the eyes at me the future of this
industry in Colombia does not look
particularly bright but maybe the future
for the planet does and the question is
is the backtracking by President petrol
enough what impact could it have for
Colombia if this President fulfills his
plans well stay tuned
from oil Miracle to oil debacle
use the words always count but a
president's statements usually count
much more with his rhetoric Petro has
burned the confidence of a sector that
was going full steam ahead in fact in
2022 investment and exploration reached
its best record since 2014. it is now
expected that in 2023 the trend will
turn around and investment will fall
again and we are talking about
concessions that have already been
signed and of course if petrol's plans
are Consolidated then the problem could
go far beyond the oil companies the
inflow of foreign currency into the
country and even the government's own
revenues we are talking about thousands
and thousands of jobs we are talking
about the fact that fuel prices could
become more expensive which would harm
the income of millions of families and
that's not even the end of it
the cessation of oil production in 10 to
15 years could also bring with it
another major problem the questioning of
the security of energy Supply why
because the Colombian electricity system
is highly dependent on hydroelectric
generation to give you an idea during
normal hydrological periods
hydroelectric generation can supply more
than three quarters of all demand
however when phenomena such as El Nino
and the resulting drought periods occur
the country has a problem so far
hydrocarbons have solved the problem but
if they run out things could become
pretty complicated because it may as you
can see Colombia seems willing to
sacrifice tens of billions of dollars
and thousands of jobs to fight climate
change and guess what now it's over to
you what do you think of Colombia's plan
and do you agree with it leave us your
thoughts and answers in the comments
below and let's open a respectable
debate as always if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so all the best thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]